[Musik]
vielleicht mein ziel ist es einfach
ausdauernd zu werden ich habe mal was
das beste was ich kriegen kann
und deswegen gibt es diesem system
sprenger begriff jedem sozialen system
gibt es leute die da raus war
[Musik]
auf den
kompost aus den federn muss
es schneit werden noch die richtigen
schnee kommt
das ist eine besondere reise eine reise
als zwischenlösung mit klarer struktur
so jetzt such mal deine handschuhe die
müssen nämlich brauchen dann hab ich das
ding gelegt
hast du wieder chaos
fünf wochen draußen leben nur leon und
der erlebnispädagoge martin emberger
und natürlich wasser sichtbar dass
werden immer klamm bei diesen
temperaturen martin seine streichhölzer
die gehen fast nicht mehr weil die alle
keinen sinn ergibt aber dann trägt
einfach durch die haare reiben sich den
extremitäten der entstehen wird das
wasser im see hier draußen fühlt sich
leon wo er wie kleine säge ein bisschen
flach sonst verpackt ist
für den jungen heißt es hier durchatmen
durchhalten und verantwortung tragen
wir waren meistens immer abwechselnd
wenn er was zu tun hat gerade mache ich
vorher machen bin ich eigentlich dabei
bin ich eigentlich mache ich dann
meister also dass da wirst du inzwischen
besser als ich drin es geht vor allem
bei diesen reise projekten darum dass
die jugendlichen mal
rauskommen
man auch da raus kommen wo es ein
bisschen anspruchsvoller ist
denn der körper kann das aber der kopf
muss es wollen und da müssen mit
millionen-klagen
das thüringer jugendhilfeprojekt wende
blatt soll eine perspektive bieten die
maßnahme mit kindern und jugendlichen zu
wandern beginnt dort wo das system an
seine grenzen stößt leon konnte nicht in
seiner familie bleiben kam als baby zu
pflegeeltern es folgten mehrere heime
und wohngruppen die letzte einrichtung
musste er jetzt verlassen werden war
eine einrichtung das immer mal so ein
bisschen gekriselt hat mit dem das war
eine regel bodengruppe und
der lehren
der macht manchmal so ein bisschen
stimmt kann man schon sagen
und hat schwierigkeiten sich an regeln
zu halten
mit der schule war es manchmal ein
bisschen schwierig bei dir die wanderung
ist jetzt eine zwischenlösung auf der
suche nach einem neuen platz verlieren
sie mich gefragt was ich gerne machen
würde ich habe gesagt so draußen
wanderte das sind sie auf dich gekommen
ja manchmal klappt es und
ansonsten geht es natürlich darum
erstmal mit sich selber klar zu kommen
also man kann erst mit den anderen
klarkommen weil man es gelernt hat mit
sich selber klar zu kommen leon ist ein
system sprenger ihm fällt es schwer
seine emotionen zu steuern bindungen zu
anderen menschen scheitern darüber zu
reden fällt ihm schwer
ich war drei jahre
schleswig holstein in der nähe von kiel
aber binde bayern geboren
naja ist halt so ich war da viel um die
welt so zu sagen
hast du noch eine mülltüte die kannst du
glaub ich gebrauchen danke
sowie ostern hast du deine handschuhe
gefunden nein die zweite taucht schon
irgendwo ja hab ich jetzt im einen
martin emberger ist
erziehungswissenschaftler und hierfür
leon bezugsperson auf die sich der junge
24 stunden verlassen kann den
13-jährigen dort zu packen wo er sich
wohlfühlt das ist der ansatz vielleicht
weil ich mal irgendwann so ein kleines
stück kaufen besonders hier und wird mit
einem holz hätte hinbauen mit dem ofen
drin
und dann drin
und youtube projekte machen kann und
elektrik allmählich werden ich bin so
gut in electric sagen ich habe so viel
gebraucht ist letzte was ich gebaut habe
waren feueralarm ich habe im alten
feuermelder genommen einen rauchmelder
und hab das hat ein bisschen gelötet und
so heute wollen sie 13 kilometer
schaffen das ziel definieren beide jeden
tag neu
[Musik]
ansonsten geht ganz stark und
beziehungsarbeit damit das jetzt mal so
nennen wollen weil ihr 24 7 unterwegs
sind miteinander wir sind keine freunde
das ist was anderes wir werden auch
keine freunde und viele müssen das
erstmal lernen zu verstehen weil wir uns
einfach nicht auf meinen augen ich mache
hier die ansagen und das ist wichtig ich
bin derjenige der hilfe und du bist
derjenige dem auch geholfen wird und du
hast natürlich nicht alle rechtzeitig
habe als jugendlicher aber du hast auch
gegenzug auf mich eine verpflichtung
sich als
richtig heraus finden laut bild lernt
wir wollen ja auch wissen dass krise
gerade brauchst du willst hast du deine
ziele sind genau das ist so schwierig
irgendwann wird jeder ort langweilig ich
denke das ist dasselbe wie für die leute
die dann jeden monat einmal umziehen
oder sowas
leons geschichte ist eine über die suche
nach halt in den letzten dreieinhalb
jahren lebte er in bayern in einer
therapeutischen wohngruppe
gerhard rausch hat ihn in dieser zeit
psychologisch begleitet durch das auf
und ab der emotionen
dieses urvertrauen das ganz am anfang
und stets das ist beim leon nicht
passiert und dieses urvertrauen dass man
dann versucht immer wieder zu finden
versucht menschen zu finden die einen
bedingungslos zur seite stehen egal was
kommt und was sein wird und wie man sich
verhält zugleich aber eine richtung
geben und einen rahmen geben ja und
diesen rahmen diese sicherheit das
spüren die und wenn es lange nicht
passiert in der kindheit dann wird es
später so dass die diesen rahmen
eigentlich einfordern zugleich aber
immer wieder test müssen bleibt der
rahmen bleibt die beziehung und da sie
selber so ein schlechtes oder so ein
negatives selbstbild von sich haben
können die gar nicht glauben dass jemand
bei ihnen bleiben möchte weil sie sich
selber ja gar nicht so wertvoll erleben
und deswegen müssen die diese beziehung
bis aufs letzte testen
das sind die momente in denen es verbal
und körperlich eskaliert und die
jugendhilfe an ihre grenzen stößt dass
sie leon gehen lassen mussten eine
schwere entscheidung wie gerhard rausch
sagt weil er weiß dass es wieder ein
abschied ist
vielen fällen ist es so dass das system
schaltet weil wir einfach nichts mehr
anbieten können wir können einfach nur
eine wohngruppe mit einem familiären
system mit bezugs erzieherin anbieten
aber trotzdem ist es für manche kinder
einfach zu wenig ja und dann ja jetzt
können wir sagen wir scheitern oder man
muss aber dann es könnte aber auch sein
dass dem kind etwas mitgegeben haben und
beim nächsten mal klappt es besser oder
an der nächsten station besser
die ist für leon noch nicht gefunden
bindungen eingehen regeln akzeptieren in
der gruppe leben das bedeutet für ihn
stress einrahmen den er in den letzten
jahren immer wieder gesprengt hat die
reise mit martin emberger soll eine
brücke bauen das projekt wird vom
jugendamt finanziert bei den 2 bis 3
monatigen wanderungen legen sie bis zu
1000 kilometer zurück
vielleicht mein ziel ist es einfach
ausdauernd zu werden ich schau mal was
das beste was ich kriegen kann
hängt wirklich grad in der luft es ist
nicht so dass die perspektive fest steht
wir suchen gerade gemeinsam mit den
lehrern die perspektive denn in die alte
wohnung gruppe würde nicht mehr
zurückgehen wir brauchen eine neue
einrichtung für den lehrern und deswegen
sind wir beide unterwegs und wir werden
uns auch in unserer gemeinsamen zeit
einrichtung anschauen da vorbei gehen
und sagen hey hier sind wir
wir sind so wie seid ihr und ein paar
bewerbungsgespräche könnte man sagen
führen und dann schauen wir was finden
wo der lärm gut ankommen kann
das liege aber auch an leon wie martin
emberger sagt sich mit sich selbst
auseinandersetzen kleine erfolge
wertschätzen kleine dinge akzeptieren
diese wanderung bedeutet auch auf
selbstverständliches zu verzichten
so eine kleine brotzeit
damit einem der gut geht also man in den
apfel zu beißen zb das zu schätzen es
schmeckt auch nicht draußen oftmals
alles anders aber allein sowas
lagerplatz sich hinlegen können wärme
trockenheit mensch bildet das ist halt
nicht mehr selbstverständlich und da
muss man sich darum kümmern muss man
muss man den arsch hochkriegen jeden tag
fast alle reise projekte ziehen die
kinder bis zum ende durch sagt martin
emberger oft dauert es monate bis
jugendämter freie plätze finden wunder
kann emberger nicht vollbringen es ist
eine maßnahme auf zeit die orientierung
geben soll beide eigen
du solltest du aber ein bisschen
windschutz und da ist die ecke
und ja darf ich hier so ja
[Musik]
wie es danach weitergeht das liegt
natürlich nur im begrenzten maße in
unserer hand den wir können irgendwie
den weg zeigen aber gegen musste in
jeder selbst und dann ist auch ein
bisschen jugendamt und die folgemaßnahme
die eltern wenn die noch eine rolle
spielen diese an der reihe dann da
weiterzumachen wo wir aufgehört haben
und auf der reise ist einfach was zu
verändern aber irgendwann geht es halt
wieder nach hause sagt die jugendliche
die wohnung nicht weit von der letzten
des lebens
draußen durchhalten sich selbst
organisieren es ist eines von
verschiedenen projekten in der
einzelfallhilfe für jugendliche in
krisensituationen eine atempause
denn er weiß nach das sind ja losgehen
da ging's los
und deswegen gibt es diesen system
sprenger begriff der das auch relativ
gut beschreibt aber dass es tatsächlich
in jedem system so jedem sozialen
systeme gibt es leute oder menschen die
daraus waren es ist dir lieber
klären wenn du alleine mit einem
zusammen ist als viele kinder mit ja ist
mir lieber
warum aber sieht nicht so der typ bin da
nicht so zusammen sein will sondern er
alleine und in ruhe
wir sind in sachen basteln na ja zb
und muss dann irgendwie ich sozusagen
geht nicht nur 20 anderen kinder betreut
werden müssen geführt
und manchmal geht es auch darum ins
unbekannte loszuziehen und währenddessen
mit prächtig an die nation entwickeln
es ist ein zwischenstopp auf leons
langer reise auf der suche nach dem
richtigen platz
[Musik]